Donald Trump's ideas aren't just
different
they are dangerously incoherent they're
not even really ideas just a series of
bizarre rants personal feuds and
outright lies it's not hard to imagine
Donald Trump leading us into a war just
because somebody got under his very thin
skin he believes we can treat the US
economy like one of his casinos he says
he has foreign policy experience because
he ran the Miss Universe pageant in
Russia he has no ideas on education no
ideas on innovation he has a lot of
ideas about who to blame but no clue
about what to do it also matters when he
makes fun of people with disabilities
cause women pigs proposed proposes
banning an entire religion from our
country or place coy with white
supremacists it matters when he says
he'll order our military to murder the
families of suspected terrorists making
Donald Trump our commander-in-chief
would be a historic mistake
imagine if he had not just his Twitter
account at his disposal when he's angry
but America's entire arsenal